now a gunman has killed an Ecuadorian
presidential candidate Fernando via
vicencio the 59 year old journalist was
one of eight candidates in the upcoming
August 20 election he was killed on
Wednesday night during an election rally
in the capital Quito it's being reported
the gunman has also been killed let's
talk to Gordon durnin he's a journalist
based in Quito and joins us via Skype
Gordon
um what more then can you tell us about
the shooting of Fernando via vicenzo and
who was he
yes hello uh Fernando via vicenzo was a
candidate running about third or fourth
place in the polls
um he was an anti-corruption candidate
um his investigations while he was in
the Congress as president of the
auditing Watchdog committee uh led to
um several uh arrests and convictions
for corruption of former Korea
government officials and in 2020 Rafael
Correa the former president himself was
arrest was convicted you know in in
absence uh and sentenced to eight years
in jail Mr Correa is currently in Exile
in Belgium
um Mr via vicencio
declared basically a war on the Korea
candidate
um Miss um
Luisa Gonzalez uh who was running in
first place uh and also
um uh has had been well known for his uh
outspoken criticism of Korea Government
yes uh Gordon so so what more do we know
about these suspected attacker I mean
there are reports he was later shot dead
yes that's been confirmed that while he
was in police custody uh one of the two
suspects that were arrested was shot
dead there are no more details about uh
how that happened or what exactly
happened
so so what's likely to be the political
Fallout then uh from this with you know
I mean the election is just 10 days away
and there's already talk uh that the
election could be canceled Gordon
yes that's correct
um the uh Supreme electoral council is
meeting currently and there are rumors
that the election could be canceled or
at least postponed uh that's the the the
rumors that are circulating right now
uh Gordon just a final thought you
before you go I mean we've recently seen
a rise in violent crime in Ecuador much
of that being fueled by the drug cartels
how big an issue has security and
violence been uh for voters uh with the
campaign Trail on
probably the
nicensio's uncle was witness to the
crime uh to the shooting uh claimed that
this this was uh what was uh leading his
uh campaign the number one issue was was
to
try and sort out the the huge security
problem in the country so he was also an
a a a a candidate that was
um uh advocating for a very hard hand in
terms of the security situation in this
country Gordon doing many thanks for
talking to us here at Al Jazeera thank
you very much indeed for your time
Gordon